MIT researchers studying
brain speech planning just
came up with the hardest
tongue twister in the world.
Anthony and Trace
here for DNews.
Toy boat, toy boat, toy
boat, toy boat, toy boat.
What are you doing?
I'm practicing tongue twisters.
It's going to be the
world's hardest tongue
twister that's just come out.
And I'm going to get it.
I'm going to get it.
OK.
You know, it's weird that
tongue twisters even exist,
if you think about it, right?
Because these are sounds
that we make all the time.
These are words that
we say all the time.
We're planning what we're
going to say in advance.
Why do we get tripped up?
That's what the MIT researchers
were looking to find.
And before you can find
the cause of something,
you have to figure out the
specific effects and what
actual things are happening
that get our tongues so twisted.
So they got this
group of volunteers,
and they gave them a whole
list of these classic tongue
twisters, and recorded
them trying to read them.
And they isolated the most
common pronunciation errors
in an effort to
start tracing back
the cause of our
brain/mouth confusion.
So do toy boat again.
OK.
Toy boat, toy boat, toy
boat, toboy, toboy--
See?
It becomes like toy boy, right?
Yeah, it's weird.
Now listen to top cop.
Got it.
Top cop, top cop,
ta-cop, ta-cop--
So the sounds are
blending together
and they're kind of
sounding crazy, actually.
And there's always
some blending,
but there's also
always some space.
Well, sometimes, right?
And it varies.
You either crush them
or you space them out.
And that happens in both short
word twisters and longer phrase
ones.
Like, the sixth sick sheik's
sixth sheep's seek six.
Exactly what I was going to say.
That's bad.
Or, Susie sits in
a shoe shine shop
where she shits-- where she sits
she shines, where she shines,
she sits.
OK.
We're really bad at this.
But what's causing
the errors, though?
They don't know.
But they do know that the
quick blending, like ta-cop,
happens more in
short word twisters.
And the spaced out blending, ta
cop, happens more in phrases.
And that might be because
the toy boat twisters have
that more-- the shorter
words in a regular rhythm,
whereas the sentences have
more irregular timing, overall.
So both errors happen in both
kinds of tongue twisters,
meaning we use the
same brain processes
for both parts of speech.
That is interesting.
But the most interesting
thing that they found
came about when they were trying
to devise different tests.
They created their
own tongue twisters,
and there was one that they
created that messed people up
so badly, they didn't even
blend sounds together.
They just locked up and
stopped speaking entirely.
Ready?
Pad kid poured curd pulled cod.
[UNISON] Pad kid
poured curd pulled cod.
Pad kid poured--
Cold.
Curd cod.
Poured cold.
Curd.
Pad.
I don't know.
Does it feel harder to you?
They are all
extremely hard for me.
If any of you guys
want to record it,
we would love to see you
trying to do it 10 times fast
and see if you fare
better than we do.
You can leave them
on our Facebook page,
or you can tweet
them to us at DNews.
And anyone who does it,
they can win five Internets.
Five Internets is
the most Internets
that we are allowed
to give out legally,
without a license
from the government.
So that is a big prize.
Enjoy it.
Pad kid pulled cod.
Curd.